my worked at McDonald's for eight years
and I think we all know why he doesn't
work there anymore
they took away all the incentives I mean
they tore down all the playgrounds
really lucky that both your opponents
look like pedophiles you know people are
asking me tonight if I'm gonna put Sarah
in her place
she's a 38 year old woman in comedy
there isn't one
ah my Kate sports obviously uh for
someone who doesn't like sports you sure
do look a lot like a 49er well it's
Canada I'm sure someone will after uh
Sarah's vagina is like a bar
it's dank full of drunk dicks and
children are immediately forced to leave
don't laugh at that don't laugh at that
Ezard like that joke was like every
tampon I've ever used despite what I've
been told I'm never shocked
sure why not
nobody cares no I Sarah you know people
think she's a she's actually real
prude she won't even put out new
material
last joke of battle Wow
thank you dirt Vonnegut that was really
funny oh man I don't I mean Mike I mean
I don't know if you guys know this but
Mike sucked a dick in college she's very
open about it that means between the two
of us on stage we both know how to
swallow a ball but he doesn't know how
to throw one
Sara does lots of tours for the troops
finally a drone they send overseas that
never kills